Fun, right?
Let's go back to the phones at (617) 830-4750
and see if we've got things.
One's a working.
Once again, let's try our color from the nine
three six area code color from nine three
six.
Can you hear me?
If so, what's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hey David, this is Robert from Houston.
Hey Robert, what's going on?
Hey, I was curious if you saw the Tim Poole,
Sam Cedar interview.
I saw like five minutes of it.
Yeah.
And I mean what, from what I saw Sam was making
a lot of sense and I wasn't exactly sure.
You know, Tim seemed to be making a point,
but then that very quickly backing away from
it when Sam would challenge it and then I
got bored and I went on to other things.
[inaudible]
so that's, that's about the right reaction
you should have had.
I mean, what did, what did you make of it?
What was the general, what was the gist of
their discussion?
Even about,
uh, it had to do with impeachment, um, is
all, cause then drifted off into sort of other
niche topics, but I'm, I'm trying to figure
out where Tim pool lands, like in the space
of the political sphere.
If he's like, I'm like a leftist.
I know that you've, you've talked to him before
and you said that you're friendly with him.
Yeah.
Like off the air and stuff.
It's a, it's just kind of strange to see somebody
who's, um, I guess reported leftist, but who
like constantly defend Trump and, and other,
uh, conservative talking.
Yeah.
Listen, I mean I think Tim is playing and
I would say this to his face and I've said
I think that Tim's politics on an issue by
issue basis.
I believe that they are left and he recently
did a political compass test and posted it
and he's on the left according to his issue
by issue positions.
Um, I think that he has found that it is good
business to play the sort of enlightened post
partisan centrist and uh, to
okay.
Take the position that he's calling out the
excesses as he sees them of the anti-Trump,
um, uh, media as he sees them and it's profitable
and it's getting them a lot of attention and
you know, but privately he's four, you know,
he checks a lot of the boxes that left check
about Medicare for all and whatever else.
I think that's basically what's going on with
Tim pool.
[inaudible]
okay.
Yeah, makes sense.
Okay, well thanks for taking my call, David.
Have a good day.
All right.
You too.
Appreciate the phone call.
Thank you